o'connor from aaas today i'm
broadcasting from my home in washington
dc
eventually there will be a coronavirus
vaccine but it will be a long time
before there's enough for everyone
how should we choose who gets it and
when how do we distribute vaccines to
countries that don't have the resources
to make their own to answer these
questions zeke emanuel
govind prasad lisa herzog and others on
a global team of ephesus
developed the fair priority model a
framework for distributing vaccines to
countries ethically and effectively
with me today with me today to discuss
their model is zika manuel
zeke is an oncologist bioethicist and
professor
at the university of pennsylvania's
pearlman school of medicine
he was a health policy advisor for the
obama administration zeke welcome
nice to be here thank you for having us
great thanks i uh
zeke i was listening to an interview
with you
i think it was done in april and uh you
uh for the um vox podcast today
explained and you mentioned that
i think you're losing sleep over the
testing situation are you are you
sleeping
no the testing situation is pretty bad
we still don't have those uh
long expected point-of-care solution
solutions where
people can you know we can have millions
of people doing it every
day but it's only one component of what
is
been uh frankly screwed up in the
american
response uh compared to every other
country its testing its ppe
its vaccines um its coordination of all
the public health measures across states
we just have not responded very well and
that is one reason
we're leading the world in terms of
mortality from covet
well we'll get into that also with us
today is govind prasad
an assistant professor at the university
of denver sturm
college of law welcome kovid
hi welcome it's great to be here
uh govind when you publish this paper on
the fair
priority model you tweeted our piece on
vaccine allocation is now out in science
magazine all those 7 a.m
mountain time zoom calls paid off are
are you sleeping cobin
um i am sleeping minimally in part
because i have a
um almost one month old uh baby but it's
um it's nice to feel like you're able to
do something um to contribute
uh globally and it was a really exciting
um
experience to be able to hear the ideas
of so many different folks thinking
about these issues from
different countries different
backgrounds
great yeah can't wait to hear more about
it lisa herzog
is a professor of philosophy at the
university of groningen in the
netherlands welcome lisa
hi thanks for having me uh lisa earlier
i was reading
that some of your work is on why
workplaces aren't more democratic like
why we don't vote
for our bosses is that right are there
are there were places that do that yes
well sort of
i mean germany has co-determination
which isn't perfect workplace democracy
but it's
far more democratic than in the us
system
and during the covet crisis there was
actually a big manifesto about the need
to democratize work
which more than 3 000 scientists
worldwide signed
because this crisis has shown among
other things that
there are all these workers out there
that really keep our societies going
and that have very little say in how
their workplaces are run in my societies
well uh my boss is almost certainly
watching this today so let's let's not
talk too much of that
um really well
meet them in the u.s interesting better
than a lot of
anyway um so getting into your
your paper in science um
uh it's called an ethical framework for
global vaccine allocation and one of the
things i wanted to talk about was
you know why do we need an ethical
framework there are a lot of medications
a lot of treatments
that we don't really or at least that i
think most people are aware of have an
ethical framework for who gets it it's
often kind of first come first serve or
whoever has the insurance
so um lisa maybe you can start
what is special about this situation
that requires this kind of response
well it's a global pandemic as we all
know
and there are huge inequalities
in the background that at the moment
seem to suggest that if nothing is done
to coordinate international action
there will be what's now being called
vaccine nationalism so
all rich countries at least will try to
get as much vaccine doses as they can
and that's going to be neither fair nor
efficient
because it will probably prolong the the
global pandemic and it will lead to far
more preventable death than if there is
international cooperation and if one
really thinks about
reasonable justifiable principles for
who should get
the doses in what order because it's a
temporal problem
eventually hopefully everyone will get
it but the question is who gets it
at what point in time yeah and that that
notion of vaccine nationalism it seems
pretty
um pervasive there was even some
discussion in the in the comments of
this post people
kind of getting at that idea and i want
to get into that a little later
um so but for for this framework you
you talk about three fundamental values
that it's
it's based on uh govan could you kind of
take us through
each of those and why you chose them
sure
um so the three fundamental values that
we focused on
that we sort of came up with by thinking
about which values get endorsed across
a variety of different frameworks
are first the value that we called
benefiting people and limiting harm so
this is a value about
um doing good making sure that the
distribution of a covet 19 vaccine um
helps to alleviate some of the really
serious harms that we're seeing harms
like
deaths um other um long-term serious
illnesses
and then obviously the indirect effects
as well that we're seeing in terms of
um poverty unemployment people not being
able to go to school
that are both bad in themselves and then
can also cause health harms
that's the first fundamental value the
second one is um
prioritizing disadvantaged
recipients of the vaccine and that's
again something that we see as a
consensus value across
different frameworks for global health
you care about benefiting people and
limiting harms but also about
benefiting people who beforehand
were more disadvantaged and then the
third from part of the framework is the
value that we call
equal moral concern which essentially
says unless you are
either benefiting people and limiting
harm or you're prioritizing the
disadvantaged
uh you shouldn't consider sort of other
factors arbitrarily
that aren't relevant to pursuing those
goals so
um you should show equal moral concern
for people
um with respect to all the other kinds
of factors that might be used
and and now zeke um
you've written i have a paper here uh by
you from 2006 about a potential flu
vaccine
um and i'm wondering you know what is
the history
of trying to solve this kind of vaccine
distribution problem and what
prior frameworks did you draw to develop
what you have here
uh colin that paper from 2006 which
started me
uh really thinking about these
allocation of
very scarce resources like flu vaccine
and a pandemic
like organs for transplantation livers
or hearts or kidneys
and now a vaccine for
coronavirus that paper in 2006 was about
distribution inside the united states
how do we decide which citizens should
get it and by the way
that discussion is alive this minute in
the united states um
where we're considering okay we're going
to have call it 30 million doses
once a vaccine is approved who is in the
top priority list who's in tier 2 who's
in tier 3
and so that's a very live discussion but
the issue of that
our paper in science address is a much
more complicated issue if you can
believe it
which is an issue of how do we
distribute the scarce resources
among countries not only does it take
public health into account
and epidemiology inside a country in the
political system in a country
it has to take international relations
economic relations
into account and to be honest when we
began this
in uh march in april we couldn't find a
single
paper that actually addressed this issue
in the biomedical literature science new
england journal lancet
it is so hard people have avoided it
like the plague
so we thought well who else who better
to address it than
ethicists from a number of countries
public health people from a number of
countries
uh both rich and poor countries um and
to really try to see if we could make
progress and from a diversity of
perspectives
um not all of these people you know uh
share the same philosophical orientation
so that's why this this this paper is so
different
subsequently as you pointed out the wh
always come out with the view um
and there may be one or two other views
that
evolve yeah i want to get into
some of the competing frameworks um
but i i also wanted to return back to
what lisa was talking about
earlier about vaccine nationalism which
which i guess is one of these competing
ideas
there was some discussion even on our
facebook page today
um and i think it's it's maybe a
reasonable kind of first cut reaction
that
whatever country makes the vaccine
should should get it
um lisa can you talk about that notion
of vaccine nationalism a bit and how it
plays into
what you've developed here but we sort
of
rejected at least um we say it's very
limited
um there was actually quite a bit of
discussion about this in the group and
there are
reasonable disagreements about how far
one can go i mean
intuitively you could say that it's a
very natural
thing that a government would try to get
as much vaccines for their people as
they can i mean they are elected if they
are elected
to look after the developer of the
country and
then if you have a vaccine producer in
your own
territory that seems to be another
reason but actually when you
think a bit more about it um which
country will have
vaccines produced first is really a
matter of
luck and also this is something that's
in the paper but
arguably there are also quite a lot of
historical
injustices that have influenced their
vaccine producing
production actually takes place and
where it doesn't take place
so that shouldn't be a determining
factor and if you just go
and let countries buy doses you you get
into you know a total sort of darwinian
law of the greatest purchasing power but
it has nothing to do with fairness or
efficiency
can i come in here and just so um
this is actually one point in which we
had a lot of disagreement in the group
there are some people who think vaccine
nationalism is more
justified um and there are people who
think
you know country borders shouldn't
matter uh at
all in terms of promoting the welfare of
people uh but we one of the things that
we agreed across
all people who were on the paper is that
even if vaccine nationalism
can be justified it's limited it's not
absolute
and let me give you an example i just
heard i was interviewed today by the
canadian broadcast company
and the interviewer said that in canada
they have
pre-orders options on orders of
230 million vaccine doses
and i'm like wait a second that's almost
eight times the population of canada
um that seems unethical because
that's a kind of hoarding uh by a
country
as i understand that britain has the
most
vaccine pre-orders per capita
of any country in the world and that
again
even more than canada that again seems
um
unethical to everyone it's unjustifiable
that you should have that much for your
population
there's a limit to how much nationalism
you can have how much priority you can
give
to your own kind and that was a very
important conclusion of the paper
right the the paper mentions this uh
kind of upper limit of
um you know you you can
give vaccines to your own population
until you reach this transmission rate
of
one um z can you explain uh
what what that number means um to our
viewers
well above one if you have a
transmission rate above one
then the disease is growing your
the number of cases is going to go up if
you have a uh
transmission rate below one it's going
to die
out because you're transmitting to fewer
than your yourselves and you're on the
downward
side and it we thought that that was a
good cutoff what a way to think about it
is
that you have a low level of cases
um and a downward slope of uh
so the number of cases is going down not
up and i think that's uh a way that you
know once you're
in that position uh you really shouldn't
be
taking more vaccines from other
countries where we know
there could be a high rate of prevalence
of the
virus and it could be going up that's a
time where you do have to recognize the
vaccine can do
more good in another country um
and the the paper mentions distributing
this
the potential vaccine in three different
phases um and govind can you tell me
what those phases are how you
arrived at them what the different kind
of ethical considerations are
at each step sure so something that i
think is
distinctive about um this
covet 19 vaccine scarcity
compared to other scarce medical
resources we might think about
is that we're expecting the availability
of the vaccine
to get better over time so you're
starting out with very little and then
over time
you're getting more and more and so um
the question is not so much who will get
a vaccine
ever but who will get a vaccine first
which countries
will get vaccines earliest on and so um
we thought about the three phases in
terms of
which outcomes were both the most
serious and the most
irreversible such that the
only or the best way of um preventing
those bad outcomes
was to use covavax 19 vaccine early on
to prevent that
and so phase one we really focus on
preventing premature deaths because we
um
suggest that that is um probably the
most irreversible
and most serious outcome and that a
metric that we suggest
integrates preventing harm and
prioritizing
disadvantaged countries then in phase
two we move to
um outcomes that aren't death but are
serious outcomes like long-term illness
and then also
outcomes like poverty and economic
decline
and then in the last phase when we
expect that you would have more vaccine
and the impact of the pandemic is less
then you turn to the sort of broader
goal of ending um disease transmission
so this is really developed
in the context of a dynamic pandemic
where you're expecting vaccine
production to ramp up over time
now um i just want to remind anyone
watching uh so i'm speaking with zeke
emanuel govind prasad and lisa herzog
about their framework
for distributing a coronavirus vaccine
around the globe
um if you have any questions feel free
to leave them in the comments we're
collecting them as we go i've got a few
here in the hopper already
lisa i wanted to ask you um
you know this uh
framework targets countries that are
doing very poorly
and i think that um one critique of it
might be that
you know are they are those countries
being rewarded for not handling this
well
and are the countries that have handled
it well uh being punished
and so how how does this model address
that
well in a way it doesn't because it's
based on the assumption that all human
lives worldwide
matter equally and people can only to a
very limited
extent if at all be held responsible for
how their governments
manage these crises and
often those who are most disadvantaged
in those countries are least likely to
have had influence on the government
this idea that you would somehow punish
governments in order to hold them
accountable
that seems to be using the population
the individual human beings
as a means in order to you know
to give give a lesson to the government
and that would seem inappropriate
i mean there are other policy tools that
you can use for international
you know expressions of um yeah
disapproval but a vaccine shouldn't be
used for that because
that's really not the purpose of a
vaccine the purpose is to
to save lives to prevent harm and so
we are not really accepting this as a
charge
um because it would contradict the very
point of
what a vaccine is all about
and and there does seem to be some some
room here for if
a country has been breaking its back to
prevent the spread and it's been hurting
its
economy that their countries
whose economies have been damaged are
prioritized as well is that right
well those where the economy has been
damaged they wouldn't be prioritized in
the first phase
first phase but in the second phase when
the focus
includes socio-economic issues then
there's a poverty index that comes in
and lots of
gdp or national product
and there if there's a poor country
where there has been a lot of economic
damage
that would put them higher on the list
in the second phase and that seems
appropriate
because it's really worse for them than
for others so
at that point they should prioritize yes
governors i think i think one point here
to elaborate
something that lisa's mentioned but i
think maybe
you know what we really care about is
individual people in their lives and how
well their lives go
we distribute vaccine to countries
because that's the mechanism we have
but in this case countries are
intermediaries they're not the ultimate
beneficiary and to hold individual
americans
responsible for donald trump's uh
performance
on you know uh coordinating the response
to
to
the pandemic and to say they don't get a
vaccine because
he hasn't done as well as he should have
that doesn't seem to hold
individual welfare at its top
that again has to be our focus all the
time
how can we benefit individuals
govind did you have something yeah this
is a i think a more minor point but
in thinking about phase two where you're
thinking about the economic impact it's
important to remember as
lisa said what we're allocating what
we're trying to use is a vaccine
to benefit people and so in some cases
you might have countries that have
been hit hard economically where the
vaccine could have economic benefits
and it makes sense to consider that in
other cases
there might be means other than covet 19
vaccines
that will be more effective at
alleviating
long-term economic effects so it's
important to remember
the tool we're talking about here in the
paper is equiva 19 vaccine
that can't be used to address every um
sort of problem
of international harm or disadvantage it
needs to be used where
the vaccine can be
the harm is of the kind that a vaccine
can prevent
as opposed to the kind that can be
addressed through money or
infrastructure or other kinds of
interventions
so so what i'm hearing mostly is
the population shouldn't be punished for
kind of the decisions or or the
happenstance of however you know their
country had to deal with it
um we have a couple questions coming in
on our facebook page
um there's one uh from
olivia josiah i hope you're i'm
pronouncing your last name right there
olivia um about
who how do we decide even who
which countries get these vaccines first
what kind of mechanism is in place
for this framework to be implemented and
who
i guess is this article um targeted to
who do you want to read it
well look it's targeted to the three big
decision makers
those are leaders of countries and you
know in particular leaders of the most
important
uh world powers that have the biggest
influence
um you know the g7 uh that can
uh alter things signatories to the
kovacs facility
it's also targeted to the leaders of the
kovacs facility
because they are going to help
distribute
uh of the vaccine um and they
have to have a framework an ethical
framework and last but not least it's
also targeted at the vaccine
manufacturers
many of them have committed themselves
to you know broad
equitable distribution of a vaccine
that's the
phraseology of the ceo of astrazeneca
they need a framework for what's an
equitable distribution and prior to
um our offering there really wasn't a
framework for
what constituted an equitable
distribution so
we were helping them give it uh with a
framework um now you know we don't have
a world government so it's not like
there's a
world parliament we can appeal to um
this
is you know you might say a little messy
but this is kind of like
standard fair and international
relations and what we're hoping is that
the ideas we've developed become the
framework that people can affirm as the
ethical approach
and we think it's uh going to be a very
efficient approach in terms of saving
lives
so there is a market for this kind of
thing it seems like a lot of companies
have signed on
or government yeah
good ad i mean this is an interesting
question of what what are the
responsibilities of
vaccine producers and we're hoping to
produce a follow-up paper
to think about that in particular
because that's in a way that's also the
other side of this national hoarding
that all these companies are now at the
moment entering into contracts with rich
countries and
promising that a certain percentage of
doses will go to them
and of course that also raises all kinds
of questions of whether it's legitimate
to maximize profits
when it comes to covered vaccines
now i uh the kind of the biggest
question that i'm getting from
facebook right now uh is
where are we with with the vaccine and i
can understand why people are
asking that um zeke do you know what's
the
what's the latest news and you know when
can we hope to put a framework like this
to work
well you know uh at the moment we have a
number of vaccines in phase three trial
uh we just had uh
johnson and johnson uh i think a week
ago uh
maybe a little more uh enter phase three
with its uh
vaccine um we still don't have a result
on october 22nd the advisory committee
at the fda
for vaccines is supposed to meet it's
unclear whether they'll have
data to review they'll review where the
various studies
are but if you listen to you know
certainly
operation warp speed um uh
and other people in the u.s government
towards the end of the year
uh maybe early 2021
we will have uh data
and that will go to the
fda to review that's certainly for the
united states we're not the only
group evaluating it you know russia has
its own
vaccine out there china has several
vaccines that it's
uh testing um it's suffice it to say
whether they
um both countries have been
i would say you know rapidly approved
after phase two without a
validation of its real effectiveness in
preventing um
uh coronavirus infection uh they're now
pursuing
uh legitimate phase three trials
we're not going to have something until
the end of the year
most likely where this framework could
influence it
but again you can't wait till you have a
vaccine to adopt the framework you have
to begin doing that work
now and that's why we work very very
hard
uh as government said every morning
every monday morning for uh
several months to really pound this out
and to create this
what we think is an ethically
justifiable and very practical
approach it seems like there was a lot
of work put into yeah
exactly that not just kind of hammering
out the
you know getting the most ethical thing
imaginable but also making it practical
um
and and govind maybe you could talk a
bit about how this framework
might uh be applicable to future
pandemics or other healthcare issues
sure so i wouldn't actually caution
against is that
with any pandemic or any health care
issue you have to consider
the um some people i think scientists
call it the sort of personality of the
pandemic
the distinctive ways in which it might
harm
some countries more than others or for
example
whether it might require um only one
vaccine
or whether you might need to have
regular booster doses or not
at the same time i think the way that it
would influence thinking about
other distribution issues is that i
think the principles
uh benefiting people and preventing harm
prioritizing the disadvantaged
equal concern those are ethical values
that i think
hold true across a variety of different
pandemics
the question of how to think about and
for any pandemic where you're expecting
production to increase over time
something like phases make a lot of
sense in terms of the specific metrics
you would use
and how to implement those that would be
something where you would need to have
information that's going to vary from
context to context about what
sorts of outcomes the pandemic or the
shortage is causing
not every health problem causes the same
kind of for instance um
economic devastation by requiring
measures that then have effects on for
instance in developing countries
um you're doing the important work
running coronavirus
but you're also concerned about if
you're getting drop-offs in
efforts to prevent malaria reference to
do childhood immunizations
um and you need to factor that in for a
transmissible disease might be different
than thinking about distributing
some other kind of scarce intervention
between countries
so we have we have uh tons of questions
coming in um we only have a few minutes
left of time um but there are a few i
want to get to here
caroline brackett asked since there will
be multiple different vaccines produced
by various companies will there be
different types of vaccines administered
in different areas
depending on production capability and i
might even
add depending on um the
individual kind of effects of the
vaccine or how it's administered
zeke you have something to say about
that colin i think
i think uh the the incredibly perceptive
question which is
you know it's complicated enough to
figure out how to put a vaccine across
all countries and as uh caroline has
pointed out
it's going to be even more complicated
in this case because
some vaccines might work better in
elderly people some might
vaccines might work better in younger
people some vaccines might have a longer
duration of action
rather than a shorter duration of action
so you may actually be having
you know multiple allocation processes
across time targeted at different
segments of
population but the fact of the matter is
at least early on
call it the first six or eight months we
won't not necessarily know the answers
to those
questions until we see how the vaccine
behaves um
when it's given to a larger population
and it's safe to say
i i think this is accurate still to
today
no vaccine has begun clinical trials
facing clinical trials in children
um and so that also is going to
complicate
matters so this is mult you have to
solve multiple
distribution problems all at the same
time
and that i think you know does add
complexity to this
uh problem i would go back to what
govind emphasized which is
we think we've given the right moral
framework the best moral framework with
the
using occam's razors the fewest ethical
principles but the ethical principles
that matter
and that will be universal that will
travel
even inside a country if we look at the
distribution inside the united states
that ethical framework those principles
should hold
it's then which metrics do you use etc
that have to be built
anew for each pandemic
lisa did you have something to add no i
was just nodding
okay yeah so i also saw um
govan and zeke you had a more recent
paper about distribution within
i think the u.s specifically but
possibly within any country
um govind can you talk a little bit
about that is that kind of
the same kind of rubric here so i think
exactly as zeke said the ethical values
that are underlying that framework
are um the same the same
ideas of benefiting people and
preventing harm
equal concern and prioritizing
disadvantaged
groups at the same time we have
different recommendations inside the us
that we would have globally
because you're looking at different the
us population
is not a mirror of the world so in our
paper in jama we say
it makes good sense to prioritize health
workers
because that enables people um
going back into health care facilities
without being scared of getting covet9
being able to go in to get things like
again dialysis childhood immunizations
all sorts of other things
um and within the us i think that makes
a lot of sense but a concern that i
would have about saying you do that
globally
which the who has talked about is that
globally
countries differ a lot in terms of
whether they have health care
professionals and so a concern i would
have about saying
you prioritize healthcare professionals
is in countries where there are not very
many of them
that's going to have um bad um effect
it's going to be unfair they're going to
be hit twice both by having
fewer health care professionals so they
can't get those services first and then
getting fewer vaccines for their
population
so what might be fear within the u.s
might not be fear in choosing between
countries
i see so it might seem intuitive to
target health care workers
and the elderly but there are vulnerable
countries that don't have many of either
of those things
um there's another question on our
facebook
from anna cropornica
that i'd like to direct towards uh lisa
this is kind of getting back to the
vaccine nationalism idea
she's asking how does government funding
in the case of the u.s
or in the case of the u.s third-party
management firm contracts
affect the distribution so you know if
our
government's money is going towards a
vaccine um
would that add to the argument that that
the vaccine should
should go to the citizens who paid for
it
or is that not happening here that's
again this question of
vaccine nationalism in which there has
been some disagreement in the group and
where we agreed that there is a limit
um for the
the basic ethical principles it
shouldn't matter because
as we emphasize it's really about saving
lives um
realistically do we expect that it will
not matter at all
probably not but and i got this question
a lot from
journalists and in europe saying oh our
governments are paying so much for this
so
why shouldn't the citizens expect that
they will get the money first
uh sorry in the vaccines first um
but still there will be some points
where even if that scenario happens
which would be bad but
it's not totally unrealistic there will
be points in time
when these western countries have had
their citizens vaccined
and then there will be another
distribution question and then the
framework might still be useful
but from the ethical perspective that
shouldn't really
be decisive so i i think we're
running to the end of our time here um
so if you've been with us this whole
time this has been
zeke emanuel govind prasad and lisa
herzog about ethically distributing
a coronavirus vaccine around the globe
before we go
maybe you could each just tell me when
there is a vaccine and we can
leave our homes again uh where is the
first place you're going to go
go the first place
i mean where i would really like to go
is i would like for my
um new uh one-month-old baby to be able
to see
his grandparents and so i think if
that's not the first place that i say
i'm going
i'm going to get a call on the phone
from my appearance
or for him to be able to see that that's
that's a
that's a very sweet answer uh lisa how
about you
i would love to play in an orchestra
again because at the moment
you can't really play music and go to
concerts and everything and
what do you play
hello that's a nice
alternative to philosophy um you spend
some time on that and at the moment this
is a little cut down
so i'm looking forward to musical life
becoming a reality again
well that sounds lovely as well uh and
zeke where where are you headed
well i'm one of those grandparents so
i have a uh two-month-old uh
my fourth uh grandchild is two months
old and
all the other ones i wanna see as well
and uh so i think that's a top priority
and my mother is 86 and i would like to
see my mother
also um and i think this just emphasizes
how
social people are and how much the
deprivation of covid19 has really been
on our social interaction
um and how desperate people i i just
watched the moment you open up
restaurants or bars
they're flooded why are they flooded
because people are social and they
really want to get together with other
people
we're no different well
uh thanks so much for for joining me i i
hope this all gets um
figured out as soon as possible so we
can we can get out to restaurants and
see our grandchildren for those of you
watching that was zeke emmanuel
govind prasad and lisa herzog on their
article
an ethical framework for global vaccine
allocation
i think there's a motorcycle driving by
you can find that at sciencemag.org
i'm colin o'connor for aaas thanks for